all right the latest reports fears about
the corona virus continue to dominate
global media today it's not a surprise
and the White House corona virus task
force added HIV expert Debbie Burks who
will report directly to the vice
president now 6600 people are
voluntarily the isolating themselves in
Massachusetts after they travel to China
smart move Australia with only 23 people
infected 15 RT released from the
hospital announced an emergency outbreak
plan it includes designating stadiums
for mass quarantines by the way most
people here think that is ridiculous not
necessary forcing entire at-risk towns
and cities to get vaccinated if one
should be developed
of course stores online retailers are
running low on n95 respirator masks even
surgical gloves 47 countries have
reported deaths the death toll is over
2,800 Italy remains the hardest hit in
Europe with 650 people infected in Italy
17 deaths Saudi Arabia has closed its
two holiest shrines to all foreigners
and the US stock market we know it
happened today took another nosedive it
was the largest single-day drop in
history for the Dow run of iris fears
ascending stock stumbling today the Dow
losing almost 1200 points the Dow and
S&P now on track for the worst week
since the 2008 financial crisis that's
not something to be taken lightly and
that's going to be something that a lot
of traders watch for all right the
president's newly appointed coronavirus
Task Force chief Vice President Mike
Pence sought to reassure the country
that the administration was being
proactive and as vigilant as possible we
will continue to bring the full
resources of the federal government to
bear to protect the American people
we're all in this together this is not
the time for partisanship this president
will always put the health and safety of
America first but even before he spoke
the usual suspects continued to launch
their wildly unfair in deceitful smear
campaign against the president and his
team of professionals on his emergency
response team now here are their 5
biggest lies lie number one VP pants
qualified to manage coronavirus task
force I expressed to him the concern
that I had of his being in this position
when he was governor of Indiana slashing
the public health budget having some
clinics one especially a Planned
Parenthood he struggled to cope with a
public health crisis on HIV by delaying
needle exchanges not a person who's
demonstrated deep understanding of
government policy related to health or
the science it's like giving children
crayons to to write in a coloring book
Oh bill weld he has so much credibility
on these types of issues
now these attacks are so pathetic
they're almost not worth dignifying with
a response
they really just hate the fact that Mike
Pence is pro-life that he doesn't
believe in enabling drug users basically
that he's not a liberal because all
those liberal governors are doing such a
great job with their states crises line
number two the response hampered by
Trump budget cuts he tried to cut back
on the CDC who's defunded Centers for
Disease Control CDC so we don't have the
organization we need we increase the
budget of the CDC why president today
and he's wiped out a lot out wrong so
wrong in fact it even The Associated
Press had to call it out reporting the
National Institutes of Health and the
CDC aren't suffering from budget cuts
financing has increased and here's a
little con law lesson from my liberal
friends Congress not the executive
branch has the power of the purse they
can always appropriate more money go to
the president say we need more money and
work out the budget between the two
branches that's how it usually works
line number three President Trump is
anti science this administration has a
war on science often for political
reasons that has really gutted expertise
I believe in not a silencing health
professionals they have not taken the
advice or the expert advice of science
scientists in their own administration
we all know that President Trump in the
course of his service has disrespected
science and scientists okay
climate change all right I love these
attacks about how Trump is anti science
from people who won't acknowledge when
life begins and who think there are like
24 genders it's all fungible spare us
the lectures of course Trump made it
abundantly clear yesterday he has trust
in his professionals inside his working
group does anyone think that if he
doesn't think changes should be made
along the way he's not gonna make them
you bet he'll make them line number four
Trump only cares about covert 19 because
he cares about the stock market reports
today is that the president has also
been more concerned about the supposed
impact on the stock market I think what
has jolted him into action is what
happened with the stock market and the
most dangerous thing he's trying to
happy talk a national health emergency
because you're worried about the stock
market I'd like to direct their
attention to exhibit a the White House
announcing the creation of the virus
task force in January and bipartisan
briefings have been happening for weeks
and weeks with officials from the HHS
and the CDC personally I don't think
that the public wants a potential health
crisis politicized to you now perhaps
after this week's reprehensible
finger-pointing cooler heads may prevail
look you know the president said to me
look I want you to reach out to the
Republican and Democrat leadership
because we want to we want to push
politics aside we want to make sure we
get the resources that we need to
respond to this to make sure the CDC all
of our agencies have the support that
they need our political leaders need to
ensure that we're both prepared and calm
in dealing with whatever comes next
the president's task force is taking
this threat seriously
they understand the need for full
transparency so calm down we have not
had thank goodness a death yet because
of this in the United States we're going
from 59 cases yesterday we wish there
were none obviously to 60 today this is
not exploding at least not yet
that is a good thing for the travel bans
maybe necessary maybe some public events
will be you know canceled even schools
may be closed in the near future for
some peer
of time maybe maybe not we don't know
yet but we're America will deal with it
and we'll deal with it smartly instead
of giving in to panic and partisanship
perhaps we should thank the good Lord
that we live in the most well-equipped
country in the world to weather these
challenges and overcome them and that's
the angle